wir haben schon einige Krisen
durchlaufen so krass wie diese habe ich
noch keine erlebt sozusagen auch in der
Polarisierung nach dem Motto wo stehst
du als wenn es sich hier um ein
Sportereignis handeln würde und auch
hier müssen wir darauf achten dass nicht
die Extremisten hier sozusagen das
Zepter in die Hand nehmen übrigens auch
politisch da passiert auch gerade eine
Menge sondern dass wir mal ein bisschen
verbal abrüsten und der erste den ich
daran erinnern würde wäre unser NATO
Bündnispartner Erdogan der von der Hamas
als befreiungs ja als befreiungsgruppe
spricht ja und noch nichtstand und damit
zündelt der das weiß der auch hier leben
so viele Millionen Menschen aus der
Türkei was machen die wenn die sowas
hören von Erdogan wann ist Schluss damit
also wann fangen wir endlich an auch zu
sagen hört auf mit Religion Politik zu
machen lasst unsere Leute hier in Ruhe
das sind unsere Bürger und es geht darum
dass wir diese Früherziehung nicht in
die Hände von verwende legen können die
damit zündeln wir haben eine Menge zu
tun